ودخلت المشفى بكامل حواسها لتلقي العلاج
لكنها عادت منه كفيفه لا تقوى على الرؤيه
ولا حتى الابتسامه او البكاء خطا طبي
افقدها حاستين في ان ووضعها في اعاقه
دائمه بين يدي والديها بهذا الحال اذا
اصبحت الطفله سدرا بعد سبعه اشهر من
تعطيها جرعات علاجيه خاطئه لا علاقه لها
بالمرض الذي اسعفت من اجله يقول والدها
بعد 15 يوم
انا اتمنى ان الله وتمني بس انت ترجع زي
ما كان الضحكه
خبره في قسم الاسعاف قتلته بالملف طوايل
الارض
قبل وقوعه لكن اهمال الطبيب في المشفى
تغلب على ذلك لتصبح سدرا واحده من بين
اطفال كثر قتلتهم تلك الاخطاء في مستشفيات
تعز هنا والده اخرى تفتش اليوم والبوم
الذكريات بحرقه عنها طفلتها التي ماتت
بنفس
الخطابه
لا اله الا الله
بداء
الاسبوع